hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ich will heute endlich mal
wieder sketchfull mit der Luke Crew ich
bin als erstes dran mit zeichnen und
würde tatsächlich die Hand nehmen ich
denke mal dass das am einfachsten ist es
ist wieder total am ruckeln
weil diese ganzen Idioten hier
wahrscheinlich wieder reinschauen guck
mal hier oben steht 90 ne 90 Sekunden
was steht jetzt gleich wenn die Zeit ja
alle neuen Sekunden haben wir hier einen
Standbild perfekt Stories gelöscht von
daher zeichne ich jetzt mal meine Hand
Zacken Daumen Zeigefinger Mittelfinger
Ringfinger kleiner Finger der kleine
sagt nichts hey guck mal wie viele Leute
hier noch joinen wollen ey Leute chillt
mal ein bisschen alle haben es erraten
außer Luna die weiß schon wie das Spiel
funktioniert oder jessy ist josing a
world los geht's meine Damen und Herren
vier Buchstaben und wir sehen auch schon
an der Uhr hier oben das ist jetzt ne es
ist es wird besser mit dem Ruckeln okay
also vier Beine es könnten äh vier vier
nee Baum nee hä ja
aber diese legs Regen auf das nächste
Wort wird gezeichnet wir haben sieben
Buchstaben und die Ruckler sind weg das
war beim letzten Video auch so dass es
leider schon nee hä
das sind doch das sind doch Grabsteine
hier wo was drauf steht und dann eine
Friedenstaube was hä oder ist das ein
groß das ist ein Croissant oder
die sind drei höher kannst du Nashorn
sein nee okay das sind hier unten
h oh egal was Bruder Malin zeichnet als
nächstes das ist ein Pulli nee Pulli
Pulli nee Jacke Jacke Jacke Jacke wie
Hose was heißt das ist mir allerdings
nicht Jacke wie Hose ist meine Damen und
Herr ist das hier vorne nicht der Smiley
ist der sonst immer steht sondern ein
Glurak und falls ihr euch fragt warum
habe ich hier die Antwort für euch das
heutige Video wird unterstützt von
Pokémon company die haben nämlich eine
neue Erweiterung für das
Sammelkartenspiel Pokémon Schwert und
Schild silberne Sturmwinde
veröffentlicht neu dabei sind strahlende
Pokémon wie z.B das strahlende chirachi
oder das strahlende Simsala habe ich
irgendeins ich habe flunky ach guck mal
eine VISA Karte die sind auch neu
schreib mir mal gerne unten in die
Kommentare wie ihr früher Pokémon Packs
aufgemacht habe ich halt immer oben so
ein bisschen was ab und dann reißt sich
so auf oh mein Gott ich habe drei quasi
wie max
okay ich habe jetzt auch gerade ehrlich
gesagt ziemlich viele Karten hier
gezogen mittlerweile habe ich hier so
einen fetten Stapel also ich habe locker
locker 15 von diesem Packs aufgemacht
das ist in meine besten ich habe
tatsächlich eine Vista flunkifer und ich
habe wie Max Rayquaza gezogen schaut
euch diese Karte mal an also ja meine
Damen und Herren hier ne so sehen die
neuen äh Packs aus das ist die neue
Erweiterung von Pokémon
Sammelkartenspiel Schwert und Schild
selber eine Sturmwinde wenn ihr da Bock
drauf habt dann checkt auf jeden Fall
mal den Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung jetzt geht's weiter
mit Sketch voll
aber seit die dumme soll doch gar nichts
gemalt
oder hängen die alle zusammen ist das
weil ich habe das
[Musik]
das ist ein Punkt
das ist ein Punkt ich muss mich echt
dran halten dicker ich bin Platz sechs
das ist eine richtig intensive Runde das
sieht aus wie eine Triangel könnte
allerdings also wirklich hinhauen weil
es um fünf Buchstaben gibt ein Bügel
ein Haken ja hier haben wir das nächste
Wort das ist ein Schmetterling ey
dritter Platz Mann Müller und Jessi
wieso seid ihr denn so Jessi sogar auf
Platz 1 Müller auf Platz ich muss mich
richtig ranhalten heute wird aber no
joke richtig gut gezeichnet zweite Runde
meine Damen und Herren choose to draw
wir machen mal eine Krake ich habe ja
Kraken als neue Angst bei mir
freigeschaltet weil natürlich Danke
dafür direkt einen Kreis gezeichnet
Kraken sind meine neue Angst weil die
tatsächlich durch jedes Loch durchgehen
können was kleiner ist als die Kopf und
eine Krake zum Beispiel riesig das Ding
ist schon erraten hier Luna so jetzt
beginnt gar nichts hier bei mir erraten
aber jetzt plötzlich am Start sein ne
genau das mache ich am liebsten Kraken
können überall durchgehen was größer ist
kleiner ist größer ist als den Kopf das
heißt selbst wenn ein Loch ist was nur
so groß ist wie der Kopf können sich da
so durchklingeln irgendwie das ist schon
total
und Julian hier noch zeigen dass es im
Wasser ist
hier kann ich euch auch hier zack die
Tentakel machen wir mal so
Krake hier haben wir eine
Schneeballschlacht ey ich bin einfach
eine verdammte Maschine ich bin kein
Mensch ich bin kein Säugetier ich bin
einfach maschinell unterwegs heute Platz
drei mittlerweile schon ey ich ich bin
sonst auch nicht so gut in gelber Kreis
Sonne
verdammt Sonne nee falsch es ist nicht
die Sonne es ist Sonnen nee Berge boah
Untergang nee Lawine Lawine Lawine
erster Platz junge was jetzt also nicht
erster Platz komplett aber in der Runde
jetzt gerade nächste Sache die
gezeichnet wird das könnten Kleid sein
passt aber nicht mit dem oh das ist
Pfeffer ich sag's euch das ist Pfeffer
das ist einfacher
[Musik]
Hashtag Hashtag
Schuss es ist aber no joke heute ein
richtig geile Runde weil jeder kann
zeichnen jeder hat eine gute
Internetverbindung und jeder ist mit
voller Leidenschaft mit dabei und es ist
echt komplette TÜV gerade
ein roter Kreis wird hier gezeichnet mit
einem blauen Ding dann oh mein Gott
Radierer nee
Radiergummi nee was ist denn das oh mein
Gott das ist eine Pille nee was ist denn
das das ist ein Mensch oh was soll das
oh das ist bestimmt richtig gut
gezeichnet wenn das schon wieder fast
alle erraten haben ey ich bin ja so hohl
rot blau Medikament nee Pille
Arzneimittel oh hey ich bin so blöd was
ist da ich habe keine Ahnung ich kenne
das nicht rot blau das ist doch diese
Farbe von diesem Radiergummi wo man blau
für cool schreiben und Rot für Bleistift
das ich kenne das nicht was haben die
hier vorher irgendwas geschrieben
Radierer nee also ähm
[Musik]
noch nie gehört hier haben wir irgendwas
grünes längliches Schlange kann nicht
sein das hat noch fünf Buchstaben aber
es sieht genauso aus wie eine Schlange
oder ist es ein Otter nee weggemacht wie
er Möhne hat genau ja Jessy hat auch die
telefonieren noch die wissen die
telefonieren alle miteinander
als nächstes eine Bärenfalle und daher
starten wir tatsächlich mit dem Bären
den ich einfach mal so zeichnen
hier und hier und läuft jetzt rum das
sind Bär mit dem Ohren mit Fell und so
überall das kann man schon erkennen dass
das mehr ist glaube ich und jetzt haben
wir aber hier unten dann tatsächlich
dieses Ding mit diesen Krallen zack was
so zuschnappt wisst ihr so und hier
unten ist schon so hier unten ist dann
der Rasen Zack und der Bär läuft hier
rein und darum geht's und so malt man
meine Damen und Herren ey Leute
komm ich mache eine Ecke die Sonne auch
früher immer oben rechts in die Ecke
gemacht hier haben wir verschiedene
Kreise die gezeichnet werden
aber das ist zu wenig das sind Bonbons
süßlich
ich bin's Tim letzte Runde meine Damen
und Herren Jolene ist am Zeichnen und
hat irgendwie das gezeichnet keine
Ahnung was das sein soll allerdings
zu raten irgendwas ihr sieht ja oben
eigentlich irgendwas mit
Traumfänger guck mal keiner hat's
erraten
ich meine dafür dass Marlin Jessie und
möhner die ganze Zeit telefoniert haben
ist es eigentlich ganz okay allerdings
will ich an der Stelle das heutige Video
jetzt auch beenden meine lieben Freunde
wenn euch mal wieder Sketch wohl mit der
Luke gefallen hat dann einen Daumen hoch
unter dem Video hier da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke um
weitere Videos nicht zu verpassen danke
auch noch mal andere Pokémon company für
die freundliche Unterstützung des
heutigen Videos und wenn ihr auch Bock
habt auf die neue Erweiterung von
Pokémon Sonne Kartenspiel Schwert und
Schild selber mit Sturmwinde dann check
den Link in der Infobox in der